okay so if we're all in the right place
what we're going to talk about today is
how to steal an election how to be
blackhat data scientists with me
Gary short so this is me and basically I
predict a feature I'm a freelance data
scientist I specialize in full stack
data ingestion storage and analytics of
large-scale data in the cloud
I also trade projections on the
prediction market right so I like to
practice and to be honest so you can
pick up predictions like this you know
this is obviously an old one well Trump
tweet about Boris Johnson by the 15th of
June you know and you can you can buy
predictions and see if they if they come
true or not you use your judgement and
your skills to to make some make some
money you don't really make money ok so
what we're going to do here what we're
doing here is I'm going to demonstrate
the place of blackhat data sides in the
process of stealing an election I
believe that blackhat data scientists
are much more dangerous than black hat
hackers black hat hackers will break
into your company and steal your data
black hat data scientists will break
into your country and steal your
democracy right way more way more
dangerous we're more effective so first
of all let's define what I actually mean
by stealing an election ok there's no
point in talking about that if we've not
defined it what I mean is to influence
the result contrary to remove of the
electorate all right now the people said
no going we'll hang on a second that's
pretty much what every political party
who are running second want to do they
want to win so they want to they want to
influence the result so yeah that's a
fair point so I might change that to to
be to illegally order morally influence
the result contrary to the mood of the
electorate all right so we're not
talking here about campaigning which you
are allowed to do okay we're talking
very specifically about illegal or a
morally influencing the result of an
election so in other words how would I
hack an election if I were a black hot
data scientist so you if you guys
anybody out there is the president of
their own small country and wish to
become I wish to stay president
small country then talk to me afterwards
and I can help you out for a for a fee
all right first of all let's talk about
a bit of disaggregation became between
amplification and influence what we're
talking about here is influence so I
want to make sure everybody understands
what what I mean and a lot of people
especially people actually who work in
social media get confused between
amplification and influence let's talk
about this guy Donald Trump Donald Trump
at the time I took the screen shot 61
point 1 million followers he is not
influencing any of these people they
were all batshit crazy before he came
along all right all he's doing is
providing amplification of those ideas
that were already around they're both
heads and ideas around the base okay so
this is just pure amplification I can
pretty much guarantee you there is
nobody in that 61 point 1 million people
who were a dedicated Democrat at the
start of the election but are sitting in
the bars in the US these days going do
you know what that Donald Trump talks a
lot a sense I might have been wrong
about my vote next election I'm voting
for that guy okay because he's not
trying to influence people he's just
trying to amplify that and those ideas
are already around so that's that's the
difference between amplification and
influence and we're only interested in
influence influence is where you were
going to do one thing but because of the
influence that we have inserted you are
going to do another thing ie what we
want you to do okay we're going to look
at this on the macro and the micro scale
any data scientist who's trying to make
a prediction will work in both the macro
and the micro scale so the macro scale
for any problem is what generally has to
happen before my prediction can be true
the micro scale is what do I do in an
individual basis in order to make that
prediction okay so for example if I were
to make a prediction about well Prime
Minister John Stone still be Prime
Minister
the next election all right or for
example will he still be Prime Minister
by Christmas next year on the macro
scale I would say but what has to happen
before the Prime Minister would change
what has to happen before we have an
election you know there's all kinds of
things that can happen they can lose a
vote of confidence all those kind things
so that's the macro skill and then the
micro scale as well given that those
things have happened what kind of things
then happen during the election to me to
make sure and that he either does or
does not remain Prime Minister so the
stuff we can do in the macro and the
microscope and we look at these things
no matter what prediction or influence
we're trying to make so first of all
let's look at the macro scale of an
election
what kind of attack surfaces does the
macro scale or this the system of
elections give us to to give us to
attack so first of all and the first
data science technique we're going to
bring to be here bring to bear here is
segmentation or clustering so clustering
is basically using techniques are used
to group data observation a few segments
so that data within the segment's are as
close together and data outside of the
segments are as far as part as possible
okay so we want to we want to take data
we want to put it into bins such that
the data which is in each bin or as
caught together as it possibly can be
and the data which is in different bins
are as far away from each other as it
possibly can be and that's just
clustering or segmentation and the
reason we do that is there is about 65
ish million people in the UK the
electorate is around 30 or 33 million
strong all right so that's a lot of
people that we have to try to influence
but if we can segment not down maybe we
can reduce the number of people that we
need to influence so bringing to bear
segmentation we can look at something
like this so this is the constituency
map of the UK there are 650
constituencies in the UK all right so
within that this is looking at the 2017
election this is a list of the 31 most
marginal seats okay from at the top
there North East Fife which only won by
two votes down here to Inver Clyde in
Scotland which only the only one bite
384 votes okay 31 seats would have been
enough to change the outcome of the
election in 2017 because it was very
close if you can't help this column here
of numbers it comes to less than 2000
people so that's why we use clustering
and segmentation as our first level
attack
we've gone from 65 million people in the
country 33 million people at the
election then to 2000 people to
influence in order to change the result
of the election right now that's a big
difference the next thing we're going to
look at is a piece of mathematics the
next pair of data signs we look at is a
piece of mathematics and particularly
this mathematics was called
gerrymandering and what it allows us to
do is to change the borders of those
constituencies to make it more likely
that we can win okay so if we look here
this is 50 people split 60% blue 40% red
okay so that you imagine any time and
that you want the looks like that if we
did perfect representation it would look
something like this we would have three
blue districts to red districts blue
wins which is correct okay but using a
bit of maths we can make the area look
compact which means we end up with five
blue districts zero red districts blue
wins again which is the right result but
but red gets nothing which is not the
correct result and then we can just do
this crazy stuff here which means
there's two blue districts three red
districts and red wins which is
obviously a fifth of the election if
that was the entire thing all right so
that's a piece of maths called
gerrymandering the next thing we're
going to talk about is tossing who here
uses a postal vote okay
did you know if your postal vote is
rejected for whatever reason nobody
needs to tell you right you post your
postal vote goes in the post box
somebody looks at it and they say no I
didn't sign it in the right place yeah
she didn't she's saying that in blue it
should have been black I'm tossing that
right it's tossed nobody needs to tell
you that your vote didn't count right
more than
importantly it didn't it never gets
recorded that your vote didn't came
right it's only the total number that
they actually tossed right not who's
they tossed okay so never use a postal
vote unless you absolutely have to okay
it happens all over the US right so
Georgia Florida New Hampshire Michigan
lots of places right this is this is not
an isolated thing it happens all over
the place happens in the UK as well in
the in the 2014 Scottish independence
referendum mi5 were accused of tampering
with the postal ballots right because
the remain campaign won in Scotland in
the postal votes by such a large
majority that people there was a
conspiracy theory that went around to
say the mi5 were actually opening the
ballots and changing them now I'm pretty
confident that didn't actually happen
but if you don't use a postal vote it
definitely can't happen okay
number four the next thing we're going
to look at is we're going to look at
something called caging now caging is
the idea of if I don't want you to be
able to vote for example I think that
you're not gonna vote for me you can't
look like somebody's not gonna support
me so I want to prevent you from from
voting right because you're gonna vote
against me so what I'm gonna do is I'm
with the ideas I'm gonna put a cage
around you right to prevent you from
voting and there's lots of different
ways to do that one of the most common
ways is for right-wing parties to cage
poor people who are most likely to vote
for left-wing parties with with more
expansive social programs all right and
it's easy to do that right it's actually
really easy to cage poor people because
if I say to you you cannot vote without
government-issued ID that sounds fair
right on the surface that sounds like a
good idea right okay if I I can't vote
unless I rock up with government-issued
ID but in this country government issued
ID means one of two things a passport or
a driver's license if you are struggling
to put food on the table chances are
you're
taking these three foreign holidays a
year and you're not skiing an aspen and
Christmas right you're probably not
driving the Ferrari to work in the
morning either right if you're working
at all you're probably on the bus so
there's a good chance you don't have a
passport and there's a good chance you
don't have a driver's license if you
have neither of these things these
things are not trivial to obtain either
okay it costs money to get both of those
things money that you may not have
without those things you can't vote
here's a map of the US and color-coded
the green color here is strict photo ID
you need a passport or a driver's
license or an ID in order to cast your
vote right down to this end which is
great no documentation okay it's about
half and half so about half the states
in the US require you to have some kind
of identification okay the darker green
ones they require strict
government-issue expensive ID so that is
without doubt caged a lot of poor people
and prevented them from voting all right
now people will tell you everybody who
does caging who engages into that they
will tell you it's to prevent voter
fraud right I don't want you voting
twice madam
definitely don't want you voting twice
for my opposition all right that is
nonsense the incidence of voter fraud in
the 14 years between 2000 and 2014 now
this is in the u.s. 350 million people
in the u.s. now okay the elektra is not
that I don't know what the Electra is in
the US right but if the entire
population is about 350 million its
loons right in the 14 years they were 31
cases of voter fraud it's something like
0.01% so nobody is doing tossing and
nobody is doing caging in order to
prevent that point zero one percent of
voter fraud right it's to steal
democracy for me that's why it's done
all right
gerrymandering tossing and caging that's
fine
but they're done by other people right
the done by government agencies are
people on committees right so how am i
if I'm idea scientist and I want to
attack that what kind of what kind of
attack surfaces do I have for convincing
people to do what I want them to do
right well I have the tried a trusted
age-old methods of doing it right I can
do bribery right you look fairly dodgy
I'm pretty sure I can dig up some dirt
on you right chances the top of that is
bribery only works while the secret is a
secret all right if somebody has paid me
in order to influence an election and
I'm betting on my ability to bribe
somebody and they've paid me a lot of
money there's no guarantee for me that
the person that I'm bribe in secret
won't come out before the election or
before I need them to act in the way
that I need them to act so it's not
foolproof it's effective but it's not
foolproof and if I'm getting paid a lot
of money I want it to be foolproof sorry
I got that completely wrong what I just
said there was if it was blackmail so
we'll just pretend I did the blackmail
one right
can't believe no one said right you can
tell you in the UK if I was in the US
some do when it's odd that's not what
bribery is you're talking about
blackmail so that'll be it downing
post-edit you know for the video we can
all laugh at it later on so let's -
let's do bribery now as if it was
blackmail right so bribery works
bribery works right if I pay you money I
can get you to do what what I want you
to do right if I say to you here's 10
pounds if you put a green card in the
box on the way out okay well tell me
what that is all it really does is
proves that you can be bought now if
somebody else stand them in the back
says I'll pay you 20 pounds if you put a
red card in the box right you pocket the
ten pounds you pocket the twenty pounds
you put the red card in here you may not
even put a card in the top okay nobody
really knows all right but again it's
not foolproof because it's just proven
that you can be bought and if you can be
bought by me you can be bought by
somebody who can afford more than I can
the best way to do it is to employ
behavioral psychology so as data
scientists we're gonna reach into other
scientific fields when I reach into
behavioral psychology because behavioral
psychology says I can absolutely
guarantee
to get you to do what I want you to do
if I can convince you that that's what
you want to do all right that's the best
way of absolutely guaranteeing that
you'll do what I want you to do so how
are we gonna do that let's have a quick
demo of what that looks like I want
somebody killed right I haven't decided
who to is yet all right but trust me
they really need it okay who here is
gonna do that for me all right
yep a couple of guys at the back
excellent right
do you out the room psychopath what I
like is the guy over here please hand up
straight we didn't even ask how much
it's a lot yeah don't care I've had one
of these days right how about one of
these days one more person talks to me
about Blaser and that's it I'm gonna
explored
I'm totally gonna totally really kill
something all right but the vast
majority of the audience right not
really interesting not really interested
in committing murder that's fair enough
all right hands up if you were a parent
guns in New York Shore fans keep your
hands up if you're up here right keep
your hands up keep your hands up if you
would kill to protect your child all
right so now that's a majority of the
people
ohright put your hands down so actually
if I could convince you that a person
was approved a clear and present danger
to the life of your child right now and
you had the means you would kill that
person so actually all I have to do to
create that scenario and I could make
more than half of you people here kill
whoever I wanted and you better believe
that if I can convince you and create a
scenario in which you would kill that I
could absolutely create a scenario
whereby you would gerrymander a few
constituencies for me because that's
nothing compared to committing murder
right so behavioral psychology is the
way to go so some of the psychological
tricks that we can use to do that right
I mean we have a lot to pick from and
we're gonna pick the ones which are most
effective to provide a tax surface to
the person that we want to influence
okay
so first of all compensation effect
compensation fetch goes something like
this
look your mom was right you've never
amounted to much
you didn't work hard at school look
you know even a menial job you work in
that small government department your
life doesn't have any meaning but I am
going to give you the opportunity the
chance here to change the direction of
the country right if you only do one
great thing in your life this is it this
compensates for your mediocre life right
that's the compensation effect that's
one way to attack that the other one is
the power of Nimes
right if I say to you what I want you to
do is to steal and subvert the election
right for how I want you to vote chances
are you're gonna go I'm not really that
interested in doing that kind of like
democracy the way it works up in a
minute well maybe no but in general okay
but if I can change the name I can say
to you look I'm gonna offer you this
chance to protect our democracy protect
our democracy by doing this thing for me
and these people are gonna come to power
and they're gonna take us out of Europe
for example we'll bring back our
sovereignty and I'll all be great that's
the power of names right it's exactly
the same thing I want you to do the
exact same thing but I've called it
something different and one is much more
powerful and much more persuasive the
broken window effect the broken window
effect and the name comes from an
experiment that was carried out in
Detroit in the 60s or 70s what happened
was and they took a they took a fairly
new fairly nice looking car and they
abandoned it and a really seedy and part
of Detroit and they watched it for 24
hours and during that 24 hours you know
what happened to the car
nothing nothing right nobody touched it
so what they did was they broke one of
the small windows at the back of the car
right we're quarterly and as soon as
that one window was broken people
thought nothing of breaking other
windows and stealing from inside it and
within within about 48 hours the car was
completely stripped okay now we can use
that same kind of psychological effect
if we can say look our democracy is
already broken right look at the state
that we are in all I'm asking you to do
is just take it one this one step
further it's not a perfect thing that
I'm asking you to break right it's
already on it
what I want you to do is just to kind of
put it out of its misery all right
that's the broken windows effect number
seven the Pygmalion effect
I love the Pygmalion effect I used this
in meetings all the time right the
Pygmalion effect says that you will
become what people see you are okay and
I love to do this because what I'll do
is I will pick the quietest person in
meetings who generally doesn't really
contribute much but you know they've got
good ideas because you speak to them at
their desk and stuff like that the full
of great ideas what I'll do is I'll pick
something an hour and I come out say all
great make great contribution today well
done awesome really appreciate that was
a great idea and within a few weeks
right a few months there they are
they're in the middle of the meeting you
know full of confidence giving their
ideas simply because somebody said
that's what they were doing anyway right
the probably wet and it probably never
opened their mouth the entire meeting
alright but you become what people see
you are right chameleon effect that was
called pressure to conform right well
we've all heard of peer pressure right
we can use peer pressure as well you can
see look in every constituency I've got
somebody a true patriot and every
constituency ready to do this for me
right are you telling me that you're not
as patriotic or as committed to the
cause of democracy as as these people in
these 649 other constituencies surely
that can't be true surely you're not
going to be the holdout amongst all
these other people all right
so pressure to conform obedience to
Authority only works with works for some
people but is is a new and is known
phenomenon throughout history there are
lots of occasions where people have done
something that they have known to be
wrong simply because an authoritative
figure told them to do so there's a
great psychology experiment you can you
can look up it's the videos are on
YouTube where people are asking people
so that the person is told that they are
helping a psychological experiment but
it's the person is this other person
who's being tested and all they have to
do is to answer questions and administer
a small electric shock when they get it
wrong okay very mild electric shock but
actually they're the
subject of the experimentation because
what happens is they ask a question
every time the other person gets it
wrong they're asked to dial up the
electricity a little bit right press the
button the guy as is getting on the
other guy who's who is pretending to be
the subject right start screaming and
yelling you should put and pleadings
like please no no no please don't please
don't give me another what's your shock
I don't think I can take it but there's
a guy there with a clipboard and a tie
of rough pins in his pocket nice white
coat no saying no it's fine trust me
it's all scientific you have to go ahead
and give the electric shock and they do
right up to almost when they think
they've killed the guy right but they're
still there pressing that down button
because there's a figure of authority
standing there with a clipboard right
telling them to do it
that's obedience to Authority system
justification 3d it's a lot bit
self-centered it's basically the system
as it is now works for me I need to keep
the system the way it is now in order to
preserve my either my status here or my
livelihood or my standard of living okay
if I can show you that your system is
under threat right I can get you to act
in the way that I want in order for you
to preserve the life that you have kind
of thing okay so those are all things
that we can attack on the macro scale
all right obviously we can't do that you
know you probably don't have an
influence into the constituency
boundaries but if you wanted to you
could use all of these techniques of
persuasion and and you know
psychological and trickery in order to
make people on these committees you do
have to say do what we're what you want
what you want us to do what we're going
to do now for the rest of the session is
we're going to look more at the micro
skill you know how we can actually
influence individual people in order to
vote the way that we want and in order
to attack the democracy so if I'm going
to attack a referendum or an election
okay there is only two ways to go there
is either the status quo what there is
no or the
change something different you can
either vote for the party that's in
power or you can vote for another party
you can either vote to remain in the EU
for example or vote to leave okay you
can either vote for Scottish
independence or you can vote for them to
remain in the EU okay
stateless chord change those are the
only two options all right now both of
those give us a bit of an attack vector
okay so if I want people to vote for the
status quo we inject fear okay
people batten all through history have
batten down when they become scared all
right
it's how forts and battlements and
castles were built okay it's because
people were there they wanted to
preserve what they had they got scared
of something
they built big fortifications it's
exactly the same if I scare you you will
vote for what you have and probably more
of it okay so it looks like this kind of
thing
No Deal breaks it would be the worst
crash since the 1930s now don't get me
wrong it isn't gonna be pretty but there
isn't going to be soup kitchens and
bread queues around the corner there's
not going to be mass unemployment people
are not gonna be throwing themselves out
of wall street windows okay it's gonna
be bad it's not gonna be that bad grexit
shock were triggering will trigger
year-long recession the Treasury warns
now the official definition of a
recession is two consecutive quarters of
negative growth so a year is basically
the smallest amount of time of session
can happen for okay so what the headline
actually says is breaks it breaks that
shock will trigger the smallest real
recession that actually qualifies as a
recession write that headline is not so
scary I love this one
good old Sunday Express in food aid for
No Deal Britain okay I feel like we're
not going to be starving right I feel
like the French and Germans are not
going to be doing the reverse of the
Berlin air drop and flying food into
Heathrow right now the attack vector
I've got if I want change is I can tell
you how much better off you're going to
be
if only you would side with me and vote
for the change that I want you to vote
for okay so it would look something like
this let's give our NHS 350 million the
EU takes every week that's got to be
good nobody's gonna vote against that
right no one is gonna vote against given
the NHS an extra 350 million a week
alright so that's the kind of change I
can vote for our money our economy our
borders our security our taxes is all
gonna be great
like all of these things are gonna be
better once we're out of the EU but what
change has an easier time because we can
also use the fear as an attack vector as
well if I want you to vote for the state
it's cool I can't really save vote for
me and things will get better because
I've been in power for the last X number
of years so it begs the question well
why are why are there not better now but
if I'm asking you to vote for change I
can do the things will get better but I
can also use fear as well
okay Turkey a population of 67 million
is joining the EU scheme and what makes
all of that kind of thing possible is
item 12 or the 12th thing from dear
science that we're going to bring to the
table is the fact that we live in a post
factual society we tend in general
probably not so much with the audience
at a tech conference but in general we
live in a post factual society and do we
care okay let's take this one the 350
billion for the EU for 350 million for
the NHS that came from the EU is such a
simple lie to debunk it's trivially
simple to look up and understand that
that is wrong but vast numbers of people
did not do that
so for a start let's just pick off the
easy ones for a start
350 million that isn't the bill well
sorry that is the bill but it's not how
much we pay because Thatcher back in the
day negotiated a rebate right now I
don't happen to know what that maybe is
off the top of my head
right but what the bill actually is is
350 million less whatever the rebate was
that she negotiate so we don't send 350
million a week to the EU right easy to
find out that's not true but even if we
did and and we do send some amount of
money we're not going to give it all to
the NHS because the EU pays for a lot of
other things in this country most
notably agricultural subsidies okay so
once we're out of the EU we'd have to
give some of the money we're receiving
to the farmers otherwise you know they
would lose the subsidy and people will
go out of business and the agricultural
economy may suffer if not claps right so
we have to do that with the money so e
we're not sending 350 million a week to
M the EU and B whatever money we are
saving we can't give it all to the NHS
because we have other stuff we need to
do with it right should really
straightforward to prove that wrong and
yet nobody did or if they did nobody
really cared let's take this one I like
this one our money we've already covered
that our economy create new job whoops
create new jobs with great new trade
deals okay maybe there will be movie
that will be great new trade deals maybe
there will be great jobs but you know
what the unemployment percentage in this
country is 3% when your unemployment
rate in the country is 3% what that
generally means is everybody who wants a
job or can't possibly hold down a job
mostly has one all right so if you're
creating all these fantastic new jobs
guess what you can't fill them unless
you've got immigration because everybody
here who's already got a job right so if
you have lots and lots of new jobs you
have enough people to fill them and our
borders a new points-based immigration
system guess what we already had control
of our borders we just chose not to
action that and our security this is the
only one that I accidentally isn't um
almost instantly debunk able all right
there are cases where we weren't allowed
to deport
and particularly terrorists because of
the human rights issue and them and
their family or not them but their
family had the right under human rights
to a family life and therefore we were
prevented from deporting the man mostly
because the women the wife and the
children were entitled to family life so
yeah that one is is actually true our
taxes we can cut v80 of household energy
bills I don't remember any politician
mentioning cutting the tax on that until
it became an EU issue right I pretty
much guarantee after Friday one of the
first things the government is going to
do is not cut v80 on energy bills right
these things are all pretty easily debug
Keable right if you just go to look up
the facts but we're live enough post
factual society and nobody ever did
including a lot of journalists and
that's almost unforgivable but for us as
blackhat dear scientists gives us a
great attack vector this is awesome this
is a good one I like this one turkey
population 67 million they mention the
population of 67 million because it's
more than the population of the UK right
now turkey is joining the EU mmm that's
what that's what a friend of mine and so
a friend of mine Kendall Miller will
call he calls that treaty in as much as
it's not a lie right but it's not the
whole truth either right
so Turkey is joining the EU they've been
joining the EU for probably around in
the last 20 years they're probably about
a good 20 to 25 years away from joining
still right because they've got none of
the things that you require right in
order to join the EU so that's not
happening anytime soon population 67
million with the footprints coming in to
the passport surely no one believes that
the entire population of Turkey is going
to move to UK on day one of them joining
the EU right that is a complete nonsense
right nobody believes that that is that
is like 10 million more people than
actually live here right now right I
mean how would the
get here by for a start I mean the be
non stop playing shuffle and fairies
never than moving from talking death
nonsense right again and we're all
laughing when we talk about it right but
a large proportion of the population
bought that because we live in a post
facto psyche we don't actually care that
that's not true it sounds good and it
makes us feel good and one of the
reasons that we live in a post facto
society and one of the attack vectors
that us living in a post facto society
gives us is that simple ideas are deemed
to be true ok it's just a psychological
fact right let me demonstrate
here's Johnson we must face the fact
that the system is spun out of control
we kind of control the numbers we cannot
control the terms in which people come
and how we remove those who abuse our
hospitality this puts huge pressure on
schools hospitals and housing right so
who here has a problem get an
appointment with a GP when they need one
ok few people who here struggle to get
their children in the school of their
first choice ok again few people who
your lives and places in the UK where
it's difficult really expensive because
of low housing to actually for your
children to actually buy a house in the
city and the country in the countryside
where they were lived in Brock right
again few people right I'll tell you the
reason for that the reason for that is
because for decades governments of all
colors right have realized that the
required investment for infrastructure
is here and they have been happy to
invest at this level ok that's why
there's not enough GPS not enough
schools not enough housing even if come
Saturday morning we send everybody home
who wasn't born in this country all
right
although happen is the required
investment we'll go from here to here
and the government who are investing
here will now be happy to invest here
right the problem will not be solved ok
because then this the solution is more
investment and governments of successive
colors for successive decades of showing
are not prepared to make that
investment now look how long it took me
to explain that to you right it's
because of the immigrants is a lot
easier to understand right it's a lot
easier to get across and it's a much
simpler idea so it's much more easy to
be believed so the fact that simple
ideas are more believable is a great
attack vector for us how do we get here
do you know what I don't actually know
how we got to a post facto Society but
the first that I became aware of it was
this the the dodgy dossier right I think
up until this most people trusted the
government right they trusted that the
government was doing the right thing and
wasn't telling lies right we believed
that they were incompetent in some
places and and in some places downright
incompetent but that's why stuff was
going wrong it was because we believed
they were fundamentally honest they were
just really at their jobs right but
after this emitter sit back and go I
don't really trust the government and as
soon as you don't trust the government
and government advisers and government
departments like the Home Office like
the Department for Health suddenly
government statistics and government
strategy and the things that they're
seeing and their statistics carry as
much we as deve down the pub or some guy
posting on Facebook as soon as that
trust is broken and that's where we are
today
and for me it started here with this
kind of nonsense 45 minutes from attack
45 minutes from attack dosser of your
Saddam is ready to launch chemical
warfare bricks 45 minutes from doom
listening me pay attention I went what
kind of miss hell's he firing for a
start because I'm going I'm sorry so
from the time that he says fire that
missile 45 minutes to spin them up and I
get all the way across here to the UK
missile is that turns out Cyprus is
within miss our range so
technically there is an RDF brace called
akka TT in Cyprus so technically Brett's
out in danger but only the RAF people
akka TT possibly maybe even so that's a
little bit misleading so how can we use
this post factor society and this idea
that simple ideas that easy to believe
and others are not how can we use this
is an attack surface here's a good
example does who here thinks the Sun has
a political agenda right okay who here
thinks the political agenda is on the
side of the Tories or the right okay who
thinks here it's on the side of the left
or labour nobody
excellent this is really interesting
watch this on the same day right this is
the headline in the English and Welsh
versions of the Sun right clearly
attacking carbon clearly on the side of
the right of the right word not the site
of right okay site of the right wing
okay
attacking the left wing okay so because
you all live in England and Wales most
of you this is the kind of thing that
you see and you then believe that the
Sun is biased towards the political
right on the same day this was the
headline in a Scottish son floppy
Johnson can't get an election which I
kinda liked to be fair
because in Scotland the biggest
constituency the Sun does not have a
political agenda right the Sun does not
have a political axe to grind is only
interested in one thing and that is
sailing papers always interested in
doing is identifying a demographic and
sailing to that demographic now here in
England and Wales the demographic that
it's identified is on the right so it
posts stuff like this on its front page
attacking the left in Scotland the
demographic that it has identified that
it wants to sell to is the SNP and the
social left so it has a front page
attacking the right okay song doesn't
have a political agenda
all right and that's how we can that's
one of the ways that we can use this
idea of post facto Society it doesn't
matter now that people hold up both
copies like I just didn't go here what
you can't trust a word the son says
right people just go there I'm still
buying it tomorrow right because we live
in a post facto Society and that means
that we can do stuff like this we can we
can be obviously on our own scale but we
can do the same thing as the newspapers
are doing is we don't have to be and we
don't have to be the same okay on both
things we can we can have contradictory
ideas and spouts contradictory stuff
contradictory simple ideas which are
easy to understand and nobody will hold
us to account we can play on this post
factual mistrust okay and by and the way
we're going to do that the most common
way of doing that is because very few
people understand probabilities and I've
noticed that that includes many data
scientists right there are data
scientists in in my experience and as a
data scientist they must point out that
N equals one samples are very poor okay
but my experience data scientists fold
to three categories there are people who
have done the work right and by the work
I mean I want to be a dear scientist so
I'm going to learn all the things that I
need to learn I'm gonna start at the
bottom and build my pyramid of knowledge
up to the top to be a data scientist so
I'm going to start at the bottom with
maths and statistics and
look at data and did a management and
all of those kind of things the second
kind are the people who were DBAs last
week and I've gone I don't think the way
things are going that the post of DBA is
going to be around in ten years time so
I'm gonna retrain and do data science
instead and they go I'm a data scientist
now okay and the third is developers who
have done the same thing and to be fair
Microsoft and other companies like that
like Microsoft have not helped because
they've gone we've democratized AI all
you need to do is Lourdes ml net and you
just access artificial intelligence like
it's any other library you've ever used
well true except you have to know
whether the results are crap or not
right you have to know whether the
results that you've got are realistic or
not okay and one of the things that a
lot of people who are now data
scientists don't understand is
probability okay so let me demo that to
you if I say to you there's an 80%
chance that it's gonna rain tomorrow a
new wake up and it's a glorious sunny
day who says I am wrong maybe six or ten
people say I'm wrong I said it was going
to be raining woke up it was sunny who
says I'm wrong okay I know a bit more
people night maybe 50 all right who says
I am right now this is a binary choice
right guys it's simple right
I'm am either wrong or I'm right
no my prediction to you is I say to you
there's an 80% chance it will rain so my
prediction is for rain tomorrow it's
sunny am I wrong I love this this is
great
it's like there's new people in the
audience going I want to say he's wrong
but he will not be asking this question
if it wasn't a trap right and there's no
way I'm falling for this right
I beat a guy restocks before right I'm
gonna put up my hand and in 10 seconds
later I'm gonna look like a right idiot
right I walked in here I walked in here
you know a law-abiding citizen and I was
only here 15 minutes before I was
murdering some guy there's no way I'm
putting my hand up again okay so
normally the thought process goes like
this right you said there was an 80%
chance it was going to rain your
prediction was for rain it was sunny
you were wrong okay the counter-argument
goes yes but you said there was a 20%
chance that it wasn't going to be
raining and that's what happened and
therefore you were right now I love
those people like those kind of people
in a second category I love them because
I can never be wrong doesn't matter what
my prediction is provided I don't say
there's a hundred percent chance X is
gonna happen it doesn't matter they will
pay me all day every day because when I
say there's an 80% chance this will
happen and it doesn't happen I go but
there was always that 20% I told you
about so I was right
the answer to the question is you can't
tell right you can't tell from one
prediction how you can tell is by a data
science a machine not machine learning a
data science principle called
calibration and to calibrate my
predictions what you have to do is you
have to take a sample of predictions
where I've said there's an 80% chance
that X will happen and a 20% chance that
Y will happen and you examine those
predictions and if X happened 80% of the
time and y happened it 20% of the time
then I am a good predictor ok but what
that also means is the best predictor in
the world
is wrong sometimes in this particular
example 20% of the time I would be wrong
but my calibration would be a hundred
percent right because 80% of the time I
said X and 80% and that happened 20% I
said Y and 20% of the time Y happened
but I would still have been wrong one
time in five and that is a brilliant
attack surface for us right because what
we can do is we can say things like this
people in this country have had enough
of experts right when experts see
economist expert economists say breaks
it's a bad idea we're going to lose
money I can't pick any one of those
experts and see and I can pick any one
of their predictions and when they've
said all there's an 80% chance of this I
just have to look at the predictions
where they've said there's an 80% chance
of X and actually Y happened and pull Y
and gone he was wrong
see look this guy he was wrong man and
he's wrong now and most people will go
yep that's true he was wrong then who's
wrong now that's a that's a simple idea
X I will believe that simple idea right
and because the vast majority of people
don't understand probabilities we get
gulf saying stuff like this people have
had enough of experts right oh my god
that is all you should have been the end
of the debate people should have just
gone I'm sorry you're an idiot right
okay another problem on another attack
surface for us is there are no rules
governing social media adverts right
there's been a big thing too thick with
the past election about Facebook saying
yeah we're not gonna do it about it plus
whatever you like right it's buyer
beware you the audience have to beware
of the adverts that you're reading on
Facebook okay now that would be fine if
the majority of the population were made
up of scientific people and technical
people like are in this audience right
but they're not they're made up of
people who are happy to live in a post
facto Society who think the government
figures carry the same way is Dave down
in the pub who believes that simple
ideas are the believable ones and who
don't understand probability and if I
can show you an incorrect
prediction from an economist you think
that economist is an idiot and doesn't
always talking about okay now I can
target ads of those people and no one
can stop me saying whatever I want
because there's no and standards agency
for social media ads and Zuckerberg
himself is gone I'm not gonna place that
that's on you have fun so here is the
big problem of that is nobody except the
targeted person or the targeted grip
going back to segmentation clustering
nobody but the targeted grip will ever
see that ad in the first place so even
if there was an agency who's gonna
complain about you because the only
people see in the advert are the people
for whom it's most targeted at who are
most likely to say I really like this
either right and are therefore not
likely to report it so it's a very
difficult area to please and that gives
us a great attack surface so now we're
gonna bring in a whole bunch of data
science techniques hair first of all
we're gonna do a BC testing okay we're
gonna we're gonna break the population
up into a script B group and see group a
grip we're gonna give them new treatment
whatsoever and we're gonna see what
happens with them the B group we're
gonna give our champion advert the one
that right now has the best success at
influencing people to do what we want
and the C group we're going to give our
challenger advert the advert which we
think is the next iteration of
successful advert for this particular
thing and then what we're going to do is
first of all we're going to make sure
that that B performs better than e so
actually giving this treatment is better
than doing nothing
showing this ad influences people more
than doing nothing and then when it does
we're going to compare that advert with
the C advert and if the C advert the
Challenger and performs better it's
going to be our new champion okay and
then we'll start the process again right
and that way and we can do this kind of
thing in business as well but here we're
talking about attacking elections
because that's sexier right by doing
that we become our own best competitor
right we're after worry about what our
other competitor
are doing right because we're our own
best competitor that si advair right
that challenge of advert to our champion
is our best competition that's ABC
testing then we can bring in between
measures testing between measures is I
ask you and are you likely to put a
green card in the box on your way out
right and then what I do is I provide
you with some kind of advert I provide
you this awesome talk right and then
they come back that's why it's called
between measures I come back after
providing a treatment and I ask you the
same question again and then I compare
the answers and if you are now more
likely to do the thing that I want you
to do compared to before the treatment I
give you then that treatment then
becomes a treatment that I can send to
everybody in your segment right so
you've proved it works for your segment
I'm not gonna send it to everybody in
that segment so that's between measures
testing uplift modeling uplift modeling
is basically a bit of modeling that we
do that allows us to break the audience
down into four categories there are the
sure things right
you're gonna do what I want you to do
regardless of what I say to you right
because you're already sold on that idea
right so I don't have to do anything I
can save my money on my adverts or
whatever it is I'm gonna do to influence
you I can save my money for that because
you're a sure thing so I'm not even
gonna send you the advert I'm gonna save
that money then there is a sleeping dogs
the sleeping dogs have negative impact
it does not matter what I do you're not
going to change your mind
alright then there are the lost causes
right those are people who are just they
are DISA they're not sleeping dogs they
are dead set on voting the opposite way
and they are completely convinced that
they are right and no one mind of
persuasion is going to change their
minds okay I'm not gonna send them
adverts
either I'm gonna target all of my
resources in this quadrant here the
people who are persuadable so by using
uplift modeling what I've done is I have
reduced
by 3/4 the cost that I've got or another
way to look at it is my budget is now
going to go 3/4 as far as it was gonna
go before because I'm only gonna target
specific people okay
8 minutes to go so in case you were
sitting there going well this is all
very entertaining and it's new it's fine
on an intellectual level but you know
it's bollocks really right nobody's
really doing this let's actually have a
look at this in the wild no I've given
this talk in Scandinavia was totally
fine I've given this talk in America and
in the UK and I thought in America if I
talk about trunk right now at least half
the audience is going to be a trump
supporter so I'm gonna get lynched if I
talk about the EU referendum in the UK
there'll be at least some people who
voted to leave here and I'll get shitty
reviews from those people right so I'm
not gonna talk about that I'm going to
talk about the SNP in Scotland right
because it'd be very few scots people
here right and all of the sensible ones
vote for the Union anyway so I don't
really care what the independent
supporting people think anyway I'm so
get a red card from that guy if he was
independent okay so let's have a look at
what they do
right so let's talk about the SNP first
thing we're gonna do is we're gonna
create a populist party now some people
get confused when I say populist party
some people get confused about that a
populist party is not necessarily a
popular party right by definition the
party that is in power is the most
popular party okay a populist party says
the party and government suck your life
sucks because of that we're on your side
right we are with the population we are
with the populace right that's what it
means so you have to be a populist party
okay and they are the SNP in Scotland
are a populist party everything good in
Scotland is a result of the SNP
everything bad in Scotland is a result
of Westminster interference and it
normally we had a dependence everything
would be awesome right so that's what
we've got to create they've already done
that
the next thing you've got to do is
silence the media right because the
media are a pain in the neck they ask
annoying questions like what kind of
currency would an independent scotland
have and absolutely the answers there's
no good answers to that question the
good answers the answers to that
question are either
we'll use the pound well that's not
independence because the Bank of England
was told interest rates or we'll create
our own Scottish pound and how long will
that take
well we don't know okay so there's no
good answer so we have to stop people
like we have to stop in the media asking
those questions and like Donald Trump's
the Donald Trump says any negative poles
are fake news right so what we're going
to do is we're just going to UM destroy
the reputation of the newspapers right
so that's one way of doing it that's the
way Trump Quinn that's not good enough
for the SMP right SNP far less subtle
than that they basically just camp out
side your offices right they believed
that the the BBC were bias in favor of
of remaining part of of the Union right
they would against Scott separation they
thought so the SNP just can't outside
their offices now it doesn't look like a
big demonstration but these guys are
noisy and this is the front door right
bears
there's the front door that's what it
looks like if you're coming to work
you'd a park here
you're gonna come through this crowd to
get in here right I don't care what
planet you are from if you're an editor
in the BBC and you've got to walk
through that in the morning you sure as
are moderate in what you see about
the SNP in future all right now that's a
big company like the BBC smaller
companies like STV which is the Scottish
television company they don't fare so
well alright so here stephen Daisley
digital politics digital politics and
comments editor for the broadcaster STV
has not had a column published in his
web site and more than a month after two
MPs who had clashed with him on Twitter
met with STV executives diesel is often
been outspoken on Twitter earning the
ire of SNP MPs Pete wisher and John
Nicholson they
actually went into their company and
basically said if you don't want to see
this you've got to do something about
that guy so they can't fire him right
because he hasn't done anything wrong so
what they did was they just stopped
using his stuff right they put them on
gardening leave right we're not sure not
gonna appear on television you are not
going to have anything published in our
blogs no one it's bit like being an inch
in Egypt you know you will be removed
from history okay and in the end no
journalist can can be a journalist under
those circumstances so he resigned next
thing you do is look at these these are
interesting right how we need to control
so that's how we're going to control
broadcast media how we can control print
media's this look at these circulation
figures right they are going down right
there's 32,000 25,000 43,000 n 235 okay
27 10 to 20 these are falling figures
right but these are not very many
figures in the independence referendum
2014 1.2 million people vote for
independence all right
those numbers are tiny compared to the
number of people who want independence
all right so how would the SNP use that
they use that by the cancel culture the
SNP have a strong cancel culture all
right so Neal Oliver as a historian he
was very outspoken in the 2014
independence referendum on the side of
the Union right divisive they put it
here in the headline in inverted commas
but devices divisive is for the SNP call
anybody who disagrees with them right
there's my view and then there's a
divisive view right you speak for the
Union therefore you are divisive right
cancel him right 170 people quit the
trust because they made him president
all right
cancel culture John Lewis let's have a
boycott of John Lewis let's have a
boycott of Waitrose let's have a boycott
of Sainsbury's
beep
supported better together let's boycott
BP let's bug I love this one it's a bank
right not only as a bank but you own the
bank right boycott the bank that you
want that's the mentality anyway you can
see you get this idea of the can take
the canceled culture No
if your circulation for your newspaper
is only twenty five thousand people
right how long do you think you could
live with a boycott not very long before
you're out of business so when the SMP
say we don't really like what you're
saying about us in our policies right
you better believe that changes
editorial policy real quick
once you've silenced the media you have
to provide your own news right so this
is Rosco who he is the strategist for
the SMP he said the main channels the
team are using include the new website
campaigning platform nation build our
social media platforms like like
Facebook Twitter Google Instagram people
who have all said they won't please
adverts and content right that's where
we're going to go right where we can't
be pleased once you've created your own
news you need to prevent outside input
into that news all right so how do we do
that is we create this thing so wings
Scotland it doesn't really matter what
they are but they are basically the kind
of unofficial leaders of the cyber nuts
okay he creates a block list with swift
at this time when I took this was all
quite well but now seven thousand eight
hundred and ninety five people on the
block list now if you're in a block list
it doesn't it doesn't only mean that you
can't see what somebody has written it
means that you can't write a reply so
what that allows the SMP to do is for
them to write any odd nonsense that they
want and you can't counter it because
you probably won't see it and even if
somebody points out to you there's no
way for you to inject your comment onto
that so all the SMP are seeing all the
SMP SMP supporters are seeing and people
that they want to influence are seeing
is their side of the news they've
cancelled mainstream
Media the creating their own news and
are stopping other people infecting that
news with a counterpoint okay we are
only one minute over now it's pretty
good for me on this talk to be honest
here is the 19 things from data science
that we extract from data science and
used in order to in order to steal
elections I recently did this talk at a
at a conference called code/mobile
States one of the things in the feedback
that they have in their feedback thing
is how useful is this to you and how
soon do you see yourself using it it's
kind of idea that if somebody shows you
Blazer how useful do you think it is
it's kind of cool when you think you'll
be using that yeah it'd be three six
months all right the feedback from my
thing says it was very useful and I'll
be using it immediately I'm not alive
that gave me pause for a second there
going in a defensive way I hope right
not necessarily in an offensive way all
right
but those are the 20 things it sorry the
19 things that we've covered and we've
learned I hope that you have learned
something if you haven't learned
anything I hope you've at least enjoyed
yourself okay we are out of time now so
if you do have questions please just
come up at the end as I'm packing up and
I will be happy to talk about this for
ever but right now we're out of time I
am keeping you from beers so thanks very
much for coming
[Applause]